a year ago I would have told most of
these nice people in search of a brand
new laptop to get a MacBook Air I
wouldn't have thought twice about it but
not anymore that's right the laptop I
once said was the best in the world it's
starting to look a little outdated at
least in comparison to some of the
newest Macs and Windows PCs that's why
we're going to start here with on a PC
guy who's getting really fed up with
Windows 8 where's the Start menu
but Jason shouldn't switch to a map just
yet he should wait for Windows 10 which
arrives on July 29th and not only does
the software look to be a huge
improvement but windows hardware is
finally catching up and in some cases
even beating Apple just look at this
Dell XPS 13 people like Jason can stop
watching now but the rest of these guys
they've got their heart set on a Mac and
good luck to them because deciding on a
Mac has never been more complicated for
every talent they have they each make
some sacrifice you can't get all the Mac
goodness in one single laptop so you
need to weigh the options take Ariel
here for example she reminds me a lot of
myself she does some light video editing
lots of photo work and spends most of
her day on email and social media but
I'm not telling her to get a 13-inch
MacBook Air that I own instead I'm
telling her to get the 13-inch MacBook
Pro Retina which is now the most well
rounded laptop Apple sells it has a far
better and sharper Retina display that
makes a real difference when looking at
images it has slightly faster
performance and the new awesome force
touch trackpad that lets you press
harder to access different shortcuts
area will lose out on the airs 13 hours
of battery life and slimmer body but the
MacBook Pro Retina did last 10 hours in
my test and it only weighs a half a
pound more the 13-inch retina is great
for Ariel but not for Gerard he's a
serious video editor who needs some real
graphics power the 15 inch retina has a
dedicated graphics card inside it even
gets eight hours of battery life Joe
here insists on getting apples crazy new
$1300 MacBook it may be a glimpse into
the future but I can't recommend it
one who isn't an early adopter this
laptop is more beautiful than anything
I've ever met the laptop is stunning and
so is its 12 inch Retina screen it's
also incredibly light and has an awesome
trackpad but there's only one USB type-c
port and the battery life is so-so and
sometimes this happens when you have a
lot of apps open so who is the macbook
air for these days well someone like my
friend Don here I mostly just need it
for email word processing and surfing
the web the air has amazing battery life
but the laptop is now feeling dated the
lower resolution screen the design the
widescreen bezel
even the last generation trackpad and
it's also the least expensive one that
is true but I also think it should be
less now and the model I recommend has
more RAM and more storage which comes
out to about $1,300 yes $1,300 the same
prices that 13-inch MacBook Pro Retina
and that all new MacBook I told you it
was confusing but hey these guys look
pretty happy oh do we get to keep these